bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
momento io sono famiglie oggi facciamo
un po di reaction ai ragazzi l'ho presa
come una roba seria nel senso che
commentare le cose che ci sono in giro
al giorno d'oggi mimì caso non so come
mai soprattutto le cose che mi
interessano ad esempio il giappone e
quindi visto che piace a voi piace a me
oggi torniamo sugli spot e giapponesi
cerchiamo di non creare troppo anzi in
realtà non c'è nessun finge le loro
pubblicità sono fatte bene noi abbiamo
l'olio cuore olio cuore mangiar bene per
sentirsi in forma quelli che mi devo
lamentare anzi io non so cosa ho visto
mi sento un ebete ma comprerei qualsiasi
cosa stessero sponsorizzando mi
sembravano dei fusilli nello spazio a
noi cioccolato avete questo il modo di
sponsorizzare del cioccolato non mungere
la mucca
questo è il modo porco demoni ma ci
voleva tanto da temi me lo compro anche
se sono allergico me lo compro ceva vi
rendete conto dei papi come tifosi come
le è venuto in mente di sponsorizzare
del cioccolato nello spazio con una
navicella gigante ragazzine maschera ma
io vi tv de maio vito tutti i miei soldi
venivo prendete non ho capito cosa sta
succedendo ma perché c'è anche no sta
usando il mio trucco porca vacca quello
di uscire dalla webcam spetta lo faccio
pure io
solo io posso fare sta cosa cioè non è
che lo facciamo tutti decidi di tutto
questo andiamo avanti
chiunque geniale sta cosa del più
bellissimo alla cava tanti chi non è la
madonna sa di un piccato che sta roba
ceca successo scusatevi scusatemi per vi
prego perché uno dovrebbe mangiare una
crocchetta e poi fare se e spuntano 20
uomini nudi che ti bocciano perché ora
ho capito subito quest'anno capito il
suo del bravissimo
io mi immaginavo che negli happy meal
giapponesi ci fossero tipo i power and
di godzilla c'è cosa in creditori la
playstation dentro le p1000 c'è tanto
non mi stupirei guarda prove sapete che
non ho mai mangiato da matthew donano sì
sì una volta per faccio vedere cosa
stavo dicendo non ho mai mangiato la
mcdonald's in giappone invece non è vero
una volta ci ha mangiato ho preso questi
che li davano insieme alle pin il in
giappone fighissimo
lo stesso anno in cui ho preso questa
splendida maglietta che ovviamente
indossato per questo video perché
mentasti così qua appena li ho visti mi
sono fottuti ho ovviamente
mi aspettavo di meglio la sta succedendo
perché c'è una tipa che vola sul divano
su della lattuga li prega costo del
mattone dal nulla poi con anfetamine
dentro sto tropicana scusatemi ma ma va
bene non sai cucino io che non so
cucinare almeno prenderli salata sealed
air va bene di abebe però non è una
persona che cosa è possibile che cosa
vedendo cos'è sta roba
[Musica]
non ho capito non ve lo giuro non ho
capito niente però mi sa un po di di
duce comando c'era lui comunque non sa
prendere l'insalata tutto il bene quel
che finisce bene però questo lo vedo
male lo vedo ma gli altri ragazzi su
sportivi ha sempre fatto pagare a dorso
réver nocetano velocissimi denti il
corrotto giochi 2020
andrea cocco risi se le mani occhi
militari nel mondo nuovo talk o grande
sport cosa cosa se vedere uno con il
funky sankyo sta male non sto capendo
neanche una parola anche contenuti cates
anche totali unexpected bellissimo non
me l'aspettavo mai che parlasse il cane
ma per quale motivo cioè completa non me
l'aspettavo mai
ha qualità ma continuò che fatta con il
caso il doppiaggio di un cane correva
iman 8 art con il motivo è una banana
questa quando sembrava banale
lo sapevo lo sapevo ma non banale un
tempo volevo tokyo lo sa che io lei e li
conosco i ragazzi alla banana pesce li
conosco già prima ancora che facciamo le
pubblicità abbiamo saputo mai
e tutto questo non ho capito cosa state
sponsorizzando banane cos'era camon che
cosa stavo guardando di melò un po tu
non ho capito niente però va bene a
sparare una buona pubblicità le forme
siamo sempre sapevo io che succeda
qualcosa di strano
robe succedono robben ed io le amo è
riuscita l'avranno ai ragazzi
ma c'è di nuovo questo carnevale
ricordatevelo gigante che scendono le
sicuro
e invece no però è sempre store a me è
sempre quella dell'altra volta anche
quello che avevo fatto visionata
pubblicità uguale questo qua che che
tipo penso sia strali iper piccante
perché questo cia le braccia nelle calze
va beh questa è partita benissimo ottuso
il professor layton mai spara no non
c'entra niente però comunque un
videogioco sicuro ma perché è perché è
imbattuto al cane al cibo per cani
seguito sms e messaggistica per cani e
messaggistica per cani cos'era perché
non mi date risposte
oddio cielo quello celo celo lui aspetta
mi piace detto ciò le cose del giappone
per porto eccolo eccolo ragazzi
rilakkuma celo celo il tipo che sta nel
esame su tipo così e lui non so che cosa
ci faccia all'interno di visto da
pubblicità che non c'entra intero sarà
uno sponsor invece una bambina che gioca
a golf in tutto questo ha delle guance
giganti ma solo caramelline va bene anzi
con la plus che già sta con la colla di
plus mcdonald's mamma mia come sempre
efficace
marco sheikho anonimi pensavo si dicesse
niente sheikh si dice marco cecato
la moglie che si è rotto il cazzo cazzo
dillo subito cazzo cazzo cazzo di
hamburger bellissimo comunque ha detto
lui e non family friendly ha detto lui
quindi ragazzi questa reaction di oggi
soddisfa giapponesi spero di portarvi
tanti altri contenuti japan mail però
per adesso io ho concluso schede del
canale sposata anche la campanellina che
trovate di fianco perché è molto
importante di messaggio tanto sui
migliori escono se volete questa
maglietta non potete e ci vediamo al
prossimo video ragazze
[Musica]